pretty - I don't know it what the
workout regimen has been for everyone
but everyone is just above well you know
I had I had to take my spot I had to
take a back seat you know I think I stay
in shape I've been you know been you
know I grew up as an athlete and whatnot
and I fancy myself you know be in shape
you looking good yeah so I get on the
first day I'm on set we're at the boxing
ring and then out comes you know Michael
B Jordan and that's 31 year old body
that was like rip like blue twisted
steel and I realized I said oh yeah
Russell you look good but you've
transitioned brother you on the other
side of the rainbow now I see Michael B
go brother 3132 you know how you're
gonna be involved in this story what
side of the ring are you on well you
know interestingly I'm right there in
the middle I play the new Pi promoter
buddy Marcel and you know people would
you know normally look at the fight
promoter sort of as Don King because he
has such an indelible mark you know in
how we look at fight promoting you know
and Don King is the showman I'm the
puppet master I've modeled my character
after al Heyman who as the the promoter
and the manager for Ford Mayweather
he's the man in the shadows and so I
sort of wanted to adopted that idea of
buddy Marcel being in the shadows being
behind the scenes more and also more
just more of a puppet master but we you
know we talking with Stephen capable jr.
who's the director and he's you know
brother that's a good idea let's let's
work with that and so we found strategic
spots further or played me more in the
back like this time you'll never see me
you never see my character in the ring
you're not sort of taking up this space
and you know looking shouldn't no see me
he's just behind saying yeah job well
done I just look to sort of bring these
two fighters together you know I Drago
in Adana Creek listen me this guy is
dangerous
don't think I could beat it speaking of
Mykleby and Sylvester Stallone what was
your favorite memory with him on set uh
you know honestly it was just for Mike
me and Michael B it was just kidding I
have an opportunity to you just to talk
to him you know between setups you know
when the scenes and just realize how
much of a beautiful you know great young
man he is he was very generous of spirit
he didn't have it he had his guard down
if he could had one and just to get to
know him and just to just to see that
he's just a regular guy younger brother
and I really appreciated that and and
again with Sly was just honestly I was
just awestruck
yeah I'm truthful I'm such a fan you
know and grew up watching all the Rocky
movies that does help raise me and I was
thinking about it this morning that
theme song you know that you know like
that just gets you that all the way I
thought about that I said that helped
like get me ready
you know everybody would absolutely so
you know it was just great just being in
his presence
and just being able to work with them
right those are dreams come true
you got people that you need you know
you've got everything to lose this guy
has got nothing to lose when it comes to
Michael B Jordan and Tessa Thompson's
characters it seems like we're bringing
on a new generation of the cream where
are we going are we gonna be in for some
big surprises would create - I think we
are gonna be in some really nice
surprises what I appreciate which is
beautiful this time around is that we
really sort of get in bet you a lot more
investment into the the villains if you
will you know the Drago story we get an
opportunity to see where they come from
to see you know Victor's Victor and his
father Ivan to see their rise you know
from their you know from their humble
fall and and sort of so we get invested
in that and then at the same time we're
invested in Adamas in you know greed and
in Bianca yes and what they're doing and
their new life that they're starting
together you know and you you get a real
it just takes you on a wonderful journey
and you're seeing you know these people
cut this this peak by the client at the
climax of the film and you're really
invested I think in both sides you know
both the divers and in Drago
when they leave the theater how are they
gonna feel
heavy you know know that it's I think
you know like I like all the like Rocky
and Creed it's a feel-good but you're
supposed to feel something so that when
we get to the climax and the payoff you
walk out of there feeling victorious
along with whoever won you know you know
the fight at the end and you walk out of
there just feeling good that I've made I
just came out of Creed - you know I
think it's gonna happen let me not seem
like it now but this is more than just a
fight